[Musique]
alors quand il a été question que je
fasse une émission culturelle sur la
chaîne paris première c'était une levée
de boucliers je me souviens que laure
adler patronne de france culture avait
appelé le patron de paris première en
dix ans vous avez quand même pas donné
une émission culturelle à tirer en
disant eh ben oui parce que le patron de
la chaîne savais que j'avais publié mon
premier livre 22 ans aux éditions du
seuil
il m'avait vu chez bernard pivot drapeau
strophes pour mon livre louis 20 il
savait ce gala qu'il n'était pas
complètement ignares or si tu es
incroyable ont tué dans une toute petite
maison à asnières n'est pas un sou au
début je me souviens le prompteur était
à manivelle
quand je faisais mes lancement comme ça
il fallait imprimer les cakes sur une
feuille de papier très longue évidemment
est quelqu'un de tourner la manière
alors pas c'était vraiment méliès on
avait le sentiment de faire quelque
chose d'utile
même si c'était difficile alors très
vite le bouche à oreille a été bon et
faire des rg comme on disait est devenu
un must dire que l'émission était
diffusée quatre fois par jour une fois à
19 heures une fois 22 heures une fois le
matin une fois l'heure du déjeuner donc
au bout d'un moment évidemment les gens
ne pouvait pas y échapper
et même s'il est pareil première gens
finissaient par l'avoir c'était en plus
la seule émission vraiment culturel à
l'époque alors la formule de l'émission
c'était très simple les trois partis il
y avait le premier tiers c'était le
journal de la culture avec elisabeth
quin philippe tesson frédéric beigbeder
patrice carmouze c'était délicieux
évidemment retrouver ces gens là tous
les jours et est un bonheur évidemment
suffi t son il commençait à nous parler
de la grèce il remontait à la grèce
antique j'ai finit pas à ce tarif là on
est le matin quoi il n'arrivait pas vous
n'arrivez pas le contrôle était sans il
était absolument génial moi je vais
logement à la culture après il ya un
tiers de débats à commencer par le
fameux débat sur le théâtre
tesson merson mais beaucoup de beaucoup
de débats et puis le troisième tiers
c'était des interviews c'est une époque
incroyable j'étais pas beaucoup payé un
petit peu quand même mais j'étais payé
pour lire des livres pour écouter des
disques et pour voir des films et ça
c'est génial c'est vraiment un boulot en
or le matin quand on se réveille on a
qu'une chose à faire c'est se cultiver
et c'est là que j'ai décidé de ne plus
avoir le trac parce que je me suis dit
mon garçon
toutes les semaines tu fais une émission
à la télé avec le trac là c'est tous les
jours tu vas être tellement malheureux
donc et celle de plus avoir le trac
parce que sinon faut vraiment que tu
change de boulot je suis resté je suis
toujours là ce que je peux vous
recommander dans la droite rive gauche
c'est l'interview de benny lévy des
milices était le secrétaire de jean paul
sartre sous le nom de pierre victor
ensuite il est parti en israël a fondé
l'école lévinassiennes et c'est devenu
un ponte évidemment de l'étude de
levinas et ce benny lévy avait m'avait
accordé une interview je ne serai jamais
pourquoi et c'est la première interview
et la dernière qu'il a donnée à la
télévision française il y avait un
garçon qui s'appelait yves adrien yves
adrien c'était le pape du pain qu un
type incroyable ami d'alain pacadis
qu'avait écrit un livre incroyable qui
s'appelait novo vision yves adrien
pareil seule interview un jour bernard
henri lévy m'appelle et me dit je t'ai
vu avec un mec sur paris première
je t'ai jamais vu aussi admiratif de
quelqu'un ah bon mais si un type avec
les cheveux jusque là avait dit oui yves
adrien dit voilà oui si on n'est pas à
venir at-il dit valent rien
je ne sais pas de qui on va être
admiratifs et que nougaro
alors on avait un décor un peu star
tient est une espèce de truc on était
assis dans une brèche tous les deux je
me souviendrai toujours de nougaro qui
ça soit en face de moi et qui me bat
voilà je suis dans le canyon jaune voilà
il était dans le canyon john eales et
michel serrault qu'elle est vraiment
rond de serviette dans l'émission qu'il
n'est sans arrêt qu'on adorait un jour
j'interviewe claude lanzmann on s'est
tellement pris la tête que l'interview a
duré 40 minutes on était obligé de
continuer après la pub tellement n'avait
pas fini de s'expliquer j'ai eu la
chance d'interviewer ettore scola qui
est le réalisateur de nous nous sommes
tant aimés qui est sans doute mon film
préféré
il faut tous les films j'ai eu aussi
zizi jeanmaire
ah oui avec des gens incroyables
beaucoup d'invités qui avait peur de
faire tout le monde en parle le samedi
soir et qu'il des denrées droite rive
gauche parce que c'était plus culturelle
soit disant main et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater
une altitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux